I feel like this they should go all out
with things they can show with its
erotic themes the three-way relationship
is just come on and you got you got
explore that just a little bit you know
I mean you know what off saying just as
long as yeah yeah that's one sane at all
I want say making great producers yeah
what's going on reject nation
Greg Alva here and John here so we just
watched the trailer for Professor Martin
and the wonder women trailer number one
boy oh boy plenty to discuss actually
now I thought it was fascinating looking
at many aspects to it I mean obviously
the trailer the main emotional component
of it is the polyamorous relationship
him getting have unlimited threesomes
these people you know difficulties
resumed in what is whatsoever it's just
like Joyride the whole thing yeah secret
okay how much you know you get two
chicks it's great but it seems like
there's a lot of emotional egg matching
our reaction we've known people who have
been in polyamorous relationships
something you know people have made of
work I've known people who it was
devastating for them they've been on for
a long time I like seeing a movie that
have those other movies I've done it but
I like seeing a movie that explores it
but I think what makes it exceptionally
fascinating was this is a guy made
wonderful vivid and the polygraph and
you see always wrapped machine we've got
to be a weird household to live in and
it makes you and the way the trailer
does it by the time at end you know ask
him to see have a secret identity kind
of makes them out to be like a little
bit of a manipulator in a way you know
he's talking about people are happier
when they have an authority to be
submissive to and they're going to
mentions that line is loving loving
authority to be submissive to this is
coming out in a very interesting time
not only because the Wonder Woman movie
just came out as a phenomenal hit all
the talk about feminism which has been
around for years already especially now
when I feel like people in media are
much more vocal than ever non feminists
right and which I which I do agree with
I think women are essentially equal what
and in feminism isn't just about women
it's Ordinary feminism is about women
being better than men only oh I believe
that's the actual definition so filling
as many men as there's a lot of false
beliefs about feminism is that it's
about equality and then men and women
are equal as an intersectional in anyway
yeah that's all false it's about women
being better than that yeah that's what
it comes down to at the end of the day
like and subscribe where they are the
real reason well when they're talking
about in the beginning because the
trailer explores it
pretty good amount in the beginning when
there's only wording one element about
you know him creating wonder woman and
how comic books are not something that
is respected being a compact writer yeah
sure is about where I see I don't know
another Oracle context to know where
that scene came from so I'm curious as
to whether that's real conversation or
like a condensed something to
communicate well it's a subject matter
that for sure existed because I remember
when all the innovations team would
Stanley when you talk about making comic
books I was a joke back then did I yeah
just so I'm thinking I like to see the
time when after this Wonder Woman movie
would gal gadot has come out and then
you're seeing the oh yeah when people
were making comic books back then that
wasn't you know something that people
respected nowadays you read a comic but
they were like you're awesome
you know that's not the response you
would get back then yeah he was like
people would read the comics but not
yeah you weren't an artist and also the
other thing too that I thought was
interesting when they were exploring
like look at what Wonder Woman comic
book is its violent there's all these
like degrading sexual actions to us and
they were showing that in the trailer I
thought it was fascinating especially
compared to today how what we view of
what Wonder Woman represents of being
the strong female empowering character
how in this like like you said we don't
know if this was a legit conversation
that took place for the female character
to be questioning Connie Britton oh yeah
for her to be questioning Luke Evans
professor Marston saying look how you're
portraying woman essentially she's
saying they're preferring them in a
horrible light in a horrible image well
that is not the image that wonder we
have a Wonder Woman today you know well
yeah reading up on the story I was
actually surprised about that because
just you know BDSM was more taboo then
than it is now you know and that was
something else surprised out in the
earlier Wonder Woman comics I don't know
if it's all I don't know what the
politics are know if it's degrading or
not I haven't read them but I know there
was a kind of heavy slant toward BDSM
flavored condoms and that's the thing
that I took out of the whole like I
wonder if you have a secret identity I
feel like the whole secret identity
illusion is like this lifestyle of yours
that's coming out through the zoo doors
or yes yeah because that's that whole
thing in the beginning where he's
talking about
people were most happy when submissive
to a benevolent you know authority of
some kind and then the relationship he
has at home with his wife and his
mistress like or their I don't know what
you call everybody who enjoys him like
that I felt like that was sort of like
are you a deviant sir you do yeah
strange things in your own time and it
totally is you naughty professor it kind
of reminds me of Kinsey in a little way
thank you that well yeah well Kinsey was
about a professor as a period piece and
it was all about sexual exploration
while this whole story is not only about
sexual exploration there's a there's a
there's a good head out through law yeah
definitely and that relationship does
look fascinating to me at a while the
Wonder Woman comic book origins is
exceptionally fascinating I think it is
cool to focus specifically on who this
guy was and the relationships he had is
it's not only about about Wonder Woman
and at first when I heard professor
Marston and the Wonder Woman as a title
I thought I would a marketing title like
that's what I first thought but after
seeing the trailer I think it's kind of
a clever title actually oh yeah
condemning isn't it in that widely
regarded that he kind of based her off
of them yeah again took a lot of
inspiration and I'm probably a lot of
input I almost feel like at this point
there would probably be a lot of leg I
wonder how much they kind of wrote
Wonder Woman you know as opposed to him
but yeah you know I feel like it's it's
a fitting title and I feel like the
movie at least what we're getting in
this trailer seems like it's presenting
a good balance of like yeah this is the
story of the guy who created Wonder
Woman but it's also an integral part of
that story is also this atypical
relationship that he has and what their
life is like and that's kind of
fascinating to me and I hope like for me
a movie like this is the end of they all
comes down to execution especially the
script I tend to trust Annapurna when
their name is on stuff they have every
suit jezus Yahoo's name released a
couple things lately that have that if
you made me wonder but uh you know
generally I like what they tend to do
and as long as this isn't written like a
TV movie I think this could be really
good I don't think so I feel like this
movie is going to be a lot edgier and
more controversial than the trailers
play I feel like it should I
like this they should go all out with
things they can show with its erotic
themes I'm interested to see the turmoil
that does take place when you have one
of these kinds of relationships you know
and I'd like Laura I'd like a movie I
like the touch of Rebecca Hall saying I
think I'm drawn to her because you're
drawn to her you know like you love
someone so much and it's kind of like
this dark lust that you're feeling at
least it's portraying it in that way I'm
not saying it's always that way if you
happen to be in one of those
relationships okay
I'm saying that the way the trailers
making it have to be it seems a little
bit on the darker side of what's a
volley but you can't get into a
relationship with somebody without there
being some difficulties and some
unexpected things and I think that
that's probably true no matter how many
people you add you'll just get a little
bit more of that each time you had to
play relationships are weird love is
weird in general we still fight all this
time to define what it is two people
an extra person you know mm-hmm who
knows and I hope that that's what this
movie kind of digs into you know and and
you know it'll be in the confines of
their actual life hopefully it's about
time we do something a little out there
seriously maybe if you're watching the
key to success clearly the professor has
figured out you create a wonder one we
need another book they they created one
one we create our female superhero now
wonder if Greg need it now people gonna
think I'm dating a new doctor this okay
you know you just add more false
information in the narratives and that's
what I do see where it goes well guys
yeah
comment below are human a polyamorous
relationship if you are tell us all the
good details
that's what common boxes are for
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell death John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram make sure to check
out our exclusive perks and rewards over
at patreon.com slash the real rejects
would love to have you join the
polyamorous community over there yeah we
were all in a relationship together it's
weird at birthdays very expensive